[Musik]
willkommen zu zdf heute live euren und
ihrem live stream zu aktuellen
diskussionen und ereignissen und das ist
natürlich weiterhin die korona pandemie
und die gestern beschlossenen maßnahmen
von bundesregierung und den 16
landesregierungen die sollen ab montag
in kraft treten einige finden sie genau
richtig andere finden sie zu lasch und
andere finden sie dann wieder viel zu
heftig und übertrieben und vor allem
auch unfair
heute wurden sie im bundestag von
bundeskanzlerin merkel noch einmal in
einer regierungserklärung erklärt und
auch verteidigt und da gab es gleich zu
anfang heftige tumulte wir schauen mal
rein was da heute morgen passiert ist
maßnahmen die wir jetzt greifen müssen
sind geeignet erforderlich und
verhältnismäßig es gibt insbesondere die
bundesgrenzen wenn er leute und sie in
einer regierungserklärung die maßnahmen
die die bundesregierung mit den
landesregierungen so ist das in unserem
grundgesetz ordnung gesprochen wenn
nicht wenn sie den präsidenten
unterbrechen kriegen sie gleich
ordnungsrufe dass ich gefährlich
ja also da ging es hoch her heute morgen
im bundestag danach ging die debatte
einigermaßen zivilisiert weiter aber
auch mit heftigen wortwechseln wir
wollen darüber sprechen heute über die
maßnahmen darüber wie sie zu
rechtfertigen sind ob sie auch ethisch
zu rechtfertigen sind mit der
vorsitzenden des deutschen ethikrates
professor alena biggs die ist uns in
berlin gleich zugeschaltet wie bewertet
sie die ganzen ergebnisse und natürlich
auch mit euch mit ihnen die
kommentarspalten sind wie immer geöffnet
ich würde wie immer darum dass möglichst
zivilisiert und freundlich miteinander
umgegangen wird sonst müssen wir da
eingreifen es gibt aber auch die
möglichkeit per mail uns was zu schicken
nämlich hier unten
das hätte er erfreute - live at zdf.de
dann werde ich schauen was dir davon mit
rein nehmen können
aber bevor wir in die diskussion
einsteigen einsteigen vielleicht noch
mal ganz kurz die gipfelergebnisse die
gucken wir uns erstmal ganz kompakt und
ganz kurz zusammen an
da ist die oberste devise kontakte
reduzieren das heißt also wir sollen auf
besucher verzichten auch nicht bei
verwandten keine ausflüge keine privaten
reisen
dann nicht mehr in bars und restaurants
gehen die werden nämlich geschlossen
genauso wie kinos theaters
fitnessstudios und freizeitparks den
unternehmen und den selbständigen die
betroffen sind wurden schnelle hilfen
zugesprochen
die sollen sich orientieren am umsatz
des novembers vor einem jahr und die
große frage ist jetzt ist das der
richtige plan oder ist das aus ethischer
sicht nicht zu verantworten und darüber
spreche ich jetzt mit professor alina
books in berlin
hallo schirm guten abend sie sind
vorsitzende des deutschen ethikrates
professorin für ethik der medizin und
gesundheit technologien an der
medizinischen fakultät der tu münchen
und direktorin des instituts für
geschichte und ethik der medien musste
ich alles ablesen lange titel hätten sie
aus ihrer perspektive sie haben ja eine
sehr sehr breite expertise der
bundesregierung jetzt mal ganz grob
gesprochen zu diesen maßnahmen geraten
also ich habe zwar das haben sie nicht
gesagt eine breite expertise aber die
bezieht sich natürlich vor allem beim
auf ethische fragen und
gesellschaftliche fragen und nicht auf
epidemiologische modellierung oder die
abschätzung wie es mit der kapazität des
gesundheitswesens aussieht deswegen kann
ich das nicht einschätzen
ich glaube aber von dem was wir in den
letzten wochen gesehen haben dass jetzt
wirklich der zeitpunkt gekommen war
indem man einfach was tun musste und im
großen und ganzen finde ich persönlich
die maßnahmen wirklich bitter und
wirklich hart aber auch notwendig große
kritik gab es heute vor allem dafür dass
die gastronomie wieder schließen muss
und auch die unterhaltungsindustrie
dabei müssen sich ja gerade die schon
lange an hygiene konzept erhalten viele
betreuen immer wieder sie würden das tun
trotzdem gibt es da kritik aber
natürlich jetzt auch viel wütende
stimmen wir haben mal mit drei
gastronomen heute gesprochen und die
haben uns das nie gesagt wenn wir gas
lohn haben uns ja hauptsächlich an alle
neuen regeln gehalten und wir haben auch
das bestmögliche dafür getan so was ich
da nicht verstehen kann warum dann die
gastronomie wieder an erster stelle
steht
was schließungen bitte
die leute haben sich jetzt nicht immer
daran gehalten sind nicht alle
vorbildlich mit abstandsregelung und so
weiter umgegangen
und genau da musste man schon oft
eingreifen natürlich
die politik könne nur das machen was die
menschen auf bäumen
er gibt immer noch so viele so viele
menschen die ihn gegen man auch nicht
daran glauben dass sie ihren real sind
deshalb diese maßnahmen weiß ich gar
nicht ob das wirklich geht optimismus
ist das letzte was man verlieren soll
dem leben
für mich kam das niemals in frage zu
schließen oder den rückwärtsgang
einlegen ich habe ja keinen ausgang aber
noch mal sagen ich kenne nur den weg
nach vorne
also es bleibt vielleicht nur die flucht
nach vorne und der optimismus trotzdem
ist die frage über die wir heute
diskutieren wollen sind diese regeln
ethisch vertretbar nicht epidemiologisch
weil wir sprechen mit professor alina
biggs der folgenden des deutschen
ethikrates und da würde ich erst mal die
frage stellen ist es ethisch vertretbar
dass jetzt eine gruppe die gastronomen
das sind nicht wenige in deutschland
pauschal mehr zurückstecken müssen als
andere die frage verstehe ich deswegen
nicht weil das nicht ganz zutrifft
das sind eben nicht nur die gastronomen
sondern das ist und das ist sozusagen
für das ganze land zu unangenehm
die gesamte freizeit branche alles was
damit zu tun hat also nicht auch
sportvereine die einfach mal ne also
trotzdem ist es ja eine gruppe es ist
andere sind nicht so sehr betroffen die
können ihren job im im home-office
weitermachen
natürlich sind die auch irgendwie
beeinträchtigt aber nicht so stark wie
jetzt diese gruppe gastronomen
unterhaltungs betriebe die
veranstaltungsbranche minimal
zusammentreffen ist das ethisch
vertretbar dass quasi eine gruppe
geschlossen sagen okay wir kriegen jetzt
mehr ab als andere
da kann ich nicht ja oder nein sagen das
wird schon aufgegriffen
das muss man sich sehr genau überlegen
ist eine ernsthafte frage deswegen muss
man die ernsthafte antworten also wenn
diese gruppe keine unterstützung kriegen
würde dann wäre das sehr problematisch
deswegen gibt es ja eine abfederung
dieser vier wochen in denen diese
gesamte branche also nicht nur die
gastronomie sondern auch die kultur der
branche zb
die so schwer betroffen sind und das ist
absolut richtig und wichtig denn die
bringen jetzt natürlich tatsächlich ein
opfer man muss sich aber auch anschauen
das im verlaufe dieser pandemie wir
fangen ja jetzt nicht an sondern wir
haben ja schon acht monate hinter uns
immer wieder verschiedene gruppen in
verschiedene art und weise opfer
gebracht haben
also wenn sie zurückdenken an frühjahr
und frühsommer da durften beispielsweise
die restaurants sehr viel früher
aufmachen weil als die kinder wieder in
die schule gegangen sind in manchen
bundesländern monate früher auch da gab
es solche ungleichgewichte dass
bestimmte gruppen einfach härter dran
waren als andere
das ist kaum zu vermeiden in so einer
pandemie und es ist immer furchtbar und
ich verstehe das sehr sehr gut ich
verstehe die frustration bei denen die
sich so viel mühe gegeben haben hygiene
konzepte umzusetzen und sich wirklich an
die regeln zu halten
aber es ist ein unbeschränkter eingriff
der abgefedert wird mit finanzieller
unterstützung wenn die denn ankommt wir
hatten ja auch schon das phänomen bei
anfang am anfang des jahres das solo
selbständige gesagt haben schön dass ich
meine betriebskosten damit bezahlen soll
aber ich darf meine miete nicht bezahlen
ich darf mein leben nicht bezahlen um
eine betriebskosten sind gering
da hat die regierung ja irgendwie nicht
weit genug gedacht oder wo hat es da
gehakt da kann ich nicht für die
regierung sprechen
das ist ja nicht meine aufgabe ich kann
nur sagen das ist jetzt tatsächlich aus
ethischer perspektive sehr wichtig ist
dass das unbürokratisch passiert und
dass diejenigen auch erreicht die das
wirklich brauchen wir haben es hier eben
nicht mit etwas zu tun was monatelang
andauern wird wo man sozusagen denn in
wien nach zahlen kann oder nachbessern
kann sondern jetzt geht es um eine
umschriebene vierwöchige schließung und
da ist es tatsächlich wichtig dass
diejenigen die da so betroffen sind dann
auch relativ schnell diese hilfe
bekommen und dass man sachen macht wie
zum beispiel bei den theatern oder bei
den bei den orchestern usw
dass die zumindest einen vorsichtigen
proben betrieb aufrechterhalten können
damit sie dann danach direkt wieder
aufmachen können das muss man ja auch
mit
ich habe hier
weil ganz gute oder interessante
wortmeldungen aus unserer
zuschauerschaft die ich finde also
einmal schreibt jungen auf youtube ist
die verhältnismäßigkeit als absolut
nicht gegeben
und wer da fehlt auch die transparenz
denn es wird zunehmend willkürlicher
zudem schadet ist der akzeptanz und das
ist tatsächlich auch da knüpft an die
der nächste kommentar an von einem user
der tatsächlich nur fbh er heißt auch
auf youtube und der schlägt zum beispiel
ganz konkret vor
in der gastronomie hätte man statt sie
zu schließen dazu übergehen können das
nur noch mit reservierungen unter angabe
des personalausweises der gäste welche
dann bei ankunft überprüft werden den
leuten zutritt gewährt wird dann kann
man sicherstellen dass niemand sich mit
pippi langstrumpf ausgeht und dass
nachverfolgbar bleibt also das wäre ja
quasi so der nächste schritt gewesen
jetzt hat die bundesregierung und die
landesplaner die landesregierung und
haben ja quasi schon voll staub
eingeführt wäre das nicht eigentlich aus
ethischer perspektive besser gewesen
jetzt mal den nächsten schritt
einzuführen anstatt alles komplett
gleich dicht zu machen also erst mal
wenn ich das nur sagen dafür ist super
wenn jemand wirklich solche konstruktive
vorschläge macht die natürlich auch
wieder umstritten sind also da ist ja
schon darum gestritten worden inwieweit
dürften beispielsweise und wird einfach
sagen kann wenn man an ferse ob das
wirklich stimmt was du da hin
geschrieben hast das ist zu spät jetzt
man muss sich klarmachen dass wir ich
weiß das ist eine floskel die hat man
immer wieder aber dies trifft einfach zu
wir sind im exponentiellen wachstum und
wir haben noch drei mal die verdopplung
zeit der intensiv zahlen dann ist da
alles dicht ja die intensivmediziner
haben heute wirklich alarm geschlagen
und das sind ungefähr 30 tage ist es ein
monat und dann gibt's kreis intensiv
bett mehr und damit in richtung
weihnachten gehen das einfach nicht lust
aber da müsste man doch sagen dass die
regierung zu spät gehandelt hat und da
irgendwie auch falsch gehandelt hat wenn
sie das nicht hätte früher also nicht
hat kommen sehen
also ich glaube sie wollen dass ich hier
in bashing loswerde
ich glaube es wäre in der tat aber hätte
hätte und wäre und so weiter ich glaube
es war richtig von der politik zunächst
mit geboten mit appellen zur arbeit
sozusagen ihr lieben leute jetzt haben
wir einen relativ entspannten sommer
gehabt jetzt müssen wir schnell
umschalten das wetter wird schlecht wir
gehen alle wieder in die in die räume
rhein wo wir wissen dass die ansteckung
viel stärker ist als draußen und wir
haben auch leider eine verbreitung
gehabt in der ganzen republik ja und
mich mal so kleine cluster sondern das
hat sich ja überall verbreitet und das
war eine phase von wenigen wochen in
denen einfach wir alle hätten sehr
schnell unser verhalten ändern müssen um
diese dynamik aufzuhalten und da hat die
politik jedenfalls in meiner wahrnehmung
schon ziemlich intensiv appelliert das
haben wir gemeinsam nicht hingekriegt
das muss man einfach auch mal so ehrlich
sagen also ich finde dass ich kann das
sehr nachvollziehen weil die politik das
ist eine sinn um mal diejenigen die
diese ganzen maßnahmen erlassen und
natürlich ärgert man sich dann über die
aber in diesem fall müssen wir irgendwie
auch alle und so ein bisschen an die
eigene nase fassen und sagen ich meine
da sind ja nicht mama und papa die
irgendwie die ganze zeit hinter uns
stehen sondern es gab eine phase in der
hätten wir sagen können sind wir sehr
vernünftig dann kriegen wir das schlecht
ohnehin jetzt ist das vorbei ist ist das
zu spät
aber jetzt ist der eindruck da hattest
du machen doch auch am morgen papa das
ist ja genau das spannungsfeld in dem
wir uns gerade bewegen also
eigenverantwortung und man guckt selber
und wenn das nicht funktioniert kommt
die bundesregierung und die und die
landesregierungen und gucken nicht den
nächsten schritt sondern machen gleich
den voll stopp wir gucken was gleich mal
an was heute im bundestag diskutiert
wurde ich habe hier noch mal drei
wortmeldungen die möchte ich gern ford
lesen weil ich sie sehr gut finde also
einmal sagt alexander frank auf facebook
auch verschiedene gruppen haben opfer
gebracht ich habe exakt seit märz alle
opfer dieser welt gebracht als solo
selbständiger musiker und seitdem
durchgehend ich habe exakt keine
unterstützung bekommen und jetzt
besitzen diese herrschaften die
verdammte stehen ihre 75 prozent
unterstützung für den november
anzupreisen
was das ganze noch absurder macht den
november 2009 10 so schlecht aus da
bekomme ich also 75 prozent von wenig
geld wie kommt man auf die idee bei
selbständigen die hilfe auf basis eines
verdammten monats zu berechnen lassen
wir einfach mal so stehen frau vreni
rossing leicht runter schreibt solange
man selbst mit dem hintern 12 ansteht so
lange heißt man alles gut aber wer man
ist irgendwann mal eine reihe ich lass
mich überraschen
und dann kommt michael lux und schreibt
auch darunter wochen wird nicht an die
privaten feiern gegangen da traut sich
keiner
gerade in der kleinen gastronomie gibt
es kaum infektionen wenn überhaupt dann
muss ich kurz ergänzen das wissen wir
nicht so richtig dieser bot dorn ist
völliger blödsinn selbst in einige
biologen das also ist welches selbst
einige biologen sagen so einer la merkel
hat die maßnahmen heute im bundestag
verteidigt in ihrer regierungserklärung
und da hat sie unter anderem dass sie
gesagt wir hören mal rein
diese konnte rückt einen begriff in den
mittelpunkt der zu unserem
grundwortschatz gehört die freiheit und
dieses mal ist es sehr konkret denn die
maßnahmen die bund und länder im
frühjahr und die wir gestern vereinbart
haben schränke die freiheit ein
zugleich spüren wir freiheit ist nicht
jeder tut was er will sondern freiheit
ist gerade jetzt verantwortung
verantwortung sich selbst verantwortung
für sich selbst für die eigene familie
die menschen haben arbeitsplatz und
darüber hinaus für uns alle
die pandemie macht uns so klar wie
selten
wir sind teil des ganzen frau professor
drucks ist das eine definition von
freiheit der sie sich anschließend
würden also interessant
in der philosophie die sich ja mit
freiheit schon seit jahrtausenden
beschäftigt gibt es diese formel dass
freiheit des einen immer dort endet wo
sie die freiheit des anderen einschränkt
und was uns das letztlich sagt ist in
einem gemeinwesen gibt es nie eine
unbegrenzte freiheit ja wir müssen das
gemeinsam gestalten dass wir alle
gleichzeitig möglichst viel freiheit
haben können alle gleichzeitig und das
auszutarieren ist letztlich etwas was
immer schwierig ist in also selbst in
den besten zeiten in einem großen
komplexen land mit vielen interessen
vielen gruppen und so weiter und so fort
in japan dem mini lernen wir auf einmal
wie sehr wir eigentlich zusammenhängen
und wie sehr wir in unseren freiheiten
eben zum teil eingeschränkt werden durch
verhalten anderer oder wie wir dann auch
freiheiten mit auf
geben müssen um bestimmte
grundfreiheiten zu erhalten müssen wir
damit leben dass ich immer auch dann
bestimmte gruppen beschweren und sagen
ich fühle mich ohne reich
ich fühle mich an meiner freiheit über
die maßen beschränkt also das ist eben
und deswegen verstehe ich diesen diesen
user beitrag geben der ein echtes herz
wenn man das hört es wird es wird nie
möglich sein in meiner wahrnehmung also
und da müssen sie so eine art den
perfekten masterplan geben und den haupt
niemand es wird nicht möglich sein das
so zu machen dass es nicht immer zu
jedem zeitpunkt eine gewisse
ungleichheit gibt gerechtigkeit nicht
dass man sagen darf ein anderer ganz
wichtiger begriff bedeutet immer
maximale komplexität denn gleich hat
eigentlich was sozusagen die strikten
maßnahmen tun
die machen ja irgendwas gleich es geht
ja dann gleich für alle im sommer hat
man sich ja sehr bemüht um so eine
differenzierung und sehr regional
flickenteppich der wurde dann auch
wieder geschimpft natürlich das sind
jetzt richtiger hammer wieder hammer
maßnahmen die einfach sehr sehr breit
wirken und die sind dann zwar für alle
gleich aber es sind nicht alle gleich
betroffen und deswegen wird das zum teil
als ungerecht wahrgenommen
da kommen wir noch mal zu diesem um
gerechtigkeitsthema ich bin da einfach
noch mal ganz kurz da rein was sie
gerade gesagt haben dass das man das
unschön findet also ich hab ich den
kommentar genau carina schreibt ihr auf
facebook mein gott nun heißen wir uns
alle mal zurück bleiben daheim und
sitzen das ganze aus immer das gezeter
es ist wie es ist also ein sehr
pragmatischer ansatz
ich fand aber auch darüber den
wortbeitrag von natalie nica gut die
ganz konstruktiv danach fragt was wird
dafür getan dass wir nach dem log dauern
die massnahmen besser umsetzen können
die betriebe besser beraten werden wie
werden die menschen darauf vorbereitet
mit dem virus leben zu können dann
locker und bringt nichts wenn es danach
weitergeht wie jetzt auch ein impfstoff
wird nicht der erlösung sondern wir
müssen lernen damit umzugehen ist das
etwas womit man tatsächlich lernen kann
umzugehen mit so einer neuen gefahr die
jetzt aufgetaucht ist gewöhnen wir uns
da irgendwann dran also den
pragmatischen ansatz das finde ich
deswegen interessant weil man daran
wirklich sieht diejenigen die das
sozusagen ertragen müssen jetzt als zum
beispiel solo und
teilnehmer oder als gastronom die haut
ist jetzt sehr sehr anders um als
diejenigen die sagen okay vier wochen
ohne essen gehen das schaffe ich schon
das zeigt diese unterschiedlichen
perspektiven
die zweite frage finde ich es eine der
ganz zentralen und das ist aus meiner
sicht eine echte auch ethische aber
natürlich auch politische forderungen
dass wir diese vier wochen die müssen
jetzt genutzt werden naja die müssen
genutzt werden für eine vorbereitung da
weiß ich auch von meinen kollegen aus
den anderen wissenschaften dass es da
schon forderungen gibt dass man den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst jetzt
einfach anders noch wieder aufsetzen
muss dass man die in dieser art der
kontakt nach verfolgung dass man da mal
drüber nachdenken muss wie man das am
besten gestaltet stichwort cluster
verfolgung dass man in betrieben aber
auch immer wieder in kultur gastronomie
bereich noch weiter optimiert und dass
wir alle besser verstehen das ist nicht
so locker lassen können wie wir das
jetzt in den letzten 12 monaten getan
haben also das ist aus meiner sicht
wirklich super kommentar weil der genau
ins herz dessen zählt was jetzt die
aufgabe ist denn dieses opfer ich sage
es nochmal was wir jetzt letztlich alle
bringen
in unterschiedlicher art und weise
absolut geschenkt aber alle bringen
opfer
das muss sich lohnen ja sonst sonst wäre
das wirklich sehr herb ich muss auch
wirklich gerade sagen ich bin echt
begeistert nachdem wir gestern die
kommentare zu machen mussten teilweise
weil es wirklich unschön war finde ich
heute sehr viele konstruktive tolle
interessante wortmeldungen banker dafür
erstmal wortmeldungen gab es auch heute
ganz viele im bundestag die erste rede
hat immer nach der regierungserklärung
die größte oppositionsfraktion das ist
die kfd und afg chef genannt hat der
bundesregierungen dann in seiner rede
kriegspropaganda vorgeworfen und meinte
dass sie angst schüren würde weil immer
diese infektionszahlen genannt werden
die steigen und dann hat er die korona
maßnahmen mit dem straßenverkehr verkehr
verglichen
und da meinte er den wird man ja auch
nicht verbieten obwohl dabei jedes jahr
viele menschen ums leben kommen gehören
da mal ganz kurz rein
es gibt eine einfache lösung die zahl
der verkehrsunfall toten auf null zu
senken
mannschaft den straßenverkehr ab
bekanntlich tun wir das nicht sondern
wir wägen ab welchen preis sogar an
menschenleben zahlen wir für welchen
nutzen so da kommt dass dieses wort ab
weg um das ist glaube ich ihr
lieblingswort als ethikerin abwägung
immer zu gucken wo gut man jetzt was
sind welche waagschale aber erstmal zu
dieser ganz konkreten frage kann man
tatsächlich die korona pandemie als mit
dem straßenverkehr vergleichen auch wenn
es so griffig ist also diese art von
abwägung das ist ziemlich coole und
ätherische abwägung ich lasse nicht mehr
trotzdem darauf ein die gute seite der
iss routil etat riss tisch können sie
das mal ganz kurz erklärt ich kaum
aussprechen
das ist eine philosophische theorie die
nach der es um die nutzenmaximierung
geht und dies bei uns in deutschland
schon in unserer verfassung eigentlich
nicht angelegt sondern wir sagen bloß
weil wir können nicht einzelne einer
nutzenmaximierung opfern insbesondere
wenn wenn das keine statistischen opfer
sind sondern wenn das tatsächlich auch
individuelle und unbestreitbare opfer
sind aber zu ihrer frage mit diesem
vergleich ich lasse mich jetzt mal
darauf ein
selbst wenn man das vergleichen ist das
natürlich krumm weil wir jetzt schon
dreimal mehr tote haben als alle
verkehrstoten im jahr zusammen und es ja
genau darum geht wie viel sind in der
zweiten welle
das waren überwiegend die toten der
ersten welle zu vermeiden dass wir
nochmal in solche zahlen kommen also
einmal davon abgesehen dass diese art
von auf rechnung wie gesagt nur in einer
bestimmten theorie funktioniert und auch
was sehr sehr zynisch es hat
funktioniert sie nicht einmal intern ich
möchte das jetzt mal positiv
interpretieren
es gibt oder also das einzige was man
daraus aus meiner sicht wirklich
gerechtfertigt ziehen kann ist und das
ist nicht das was da formuliert wurde
das ist natürlich auf dauer nicht
gelingen wird und auch nicht gelingen
sollte und darf dass wir sozusagen auch
0 risiken abzielen das wird nicht das
wird nicht funktionieren
das hat gesagt er hat gesagt also das
wird man nicht erreichen und dann muss
man halt damit leben dass es halt
bestimmte schäden gibt es ist das dann
so dass man damit leben muss dass
bestimmte schäden gibt und man abwägen
was okay wir das machen jetzt den
schaden man das machen gibt es den
schaden ja das ist eben nicht immer so
wie sagen wir am mathematischen
reißbrett wo man hin oder her schiebt
absehbar aber das sagt mir nur die afd
das sagen sehr viele andere auch dass
wir lernen müssen auch in der pandemie
mit risiken umzugehen und in meiner
wahrnehmung tun wird dass deswegen ihre
frage von vorhin deswegen beispielsweise
gehe ich davon aus dass diese maßnahmen
von der regierung jetzt beschlossen
wurden und nicht schon vor vier wochen
ja denn da hätte man natürlich diese
kurve noch viel früher abgefangen wir
hoffen dass wir sie als abfangen können
aber damals wird abgewogen worden seien
nämlich auch noch gesagt haben
der druck ist noch nicht so hoch dass
wir jetzt schon diese folgeschäden die
wirtschaftlichen die psychischen
sozialen und so weiter dieser starken
maßnahmen in kauf nehmen können also ich
glaube diese art von abwägung wie gesagt
schwieriges wort muss man immer die
franzi was damit gemeint ist aber die
läuft tatsächlich die ganze zeit und das
lernen mit den risiken umzugehen ist
auch etwas was die ganze zeit abläuft
und das ist wirklich wichtig denn es
stimmt dass uns auch die impfung von der
wir hoffen oder die impfungen von dem
wir hoffen dass sie bald kommen nicht
auf einmal das problem wegnehmen werden
sondern wir werden einfach nur eine
ganze zeit in dieser pandemie leben ich
habe ja noch eine abwägungsfrage für sie
frau prof
hier gucken sie mal abschalten auch
meinen rechner
da gibt es einen kommentar auf youtube
von lily flower und die schreibt mich
würde mal interessieren was frau büxt
dazu sagt ob es ethisch okay ist gesunde
menschen durch maßnahmen psychisch krank
zu machen
denn das passiert ja momentan das ist ja
auch eine abwägungssache
man stützt menschen körperlich und
anderen schadet man dadurch psychisch
genau das sind diese ganzen
güterabwägungen die die ganze zeit läuft
nur das ist das war die frage als es um
die kinder beispielsweise gegen die doch
viele viele monate lang überhaupt keine
keinen austausch haben konnten keine
ihre bildungs erfahrung nicht mehr
machen konnten schon von den ganz
kleinen an die einfach überhaupt nicht
weil wir wissen ja auch bei kindern wie
wichtig die die soziale wie andere
kinder für die soziale entwicklung sind
das sind eben die folgeschäden
die müssen immer berücksichtigt wäre
aber können wir die überhaupt evaluieren
so richtig ich meine gerade psychische
schäden zu evaluieren also dass
zusammenzurechnen wo ich wie hoch der
ist das ist sehr viel schwieriger als
menschen auf intensivstationen zu zählen
ja ich finde das deswegen auch wirklich
einen guten nehmen weiß ich habe das
heute schon mal irgendwann anders gesagt
diese ganze psychische belastung die
psychische seite ist in meiner
wahrnehmung wirklich unterbelichtet dies
sehr wichtig todesfälle sind das eine
und das ist natürlich das
schreckenszenario schwere und schwerste
krankheitsfälle intensivstation beatmung
und sobald das ist ein aber wir haben da
einen ganzen bereich also auch die
erkrankung diese sogenannten longo witt
fälle wo leute nämlich gar nicht
auftauchen in der todes statistik und
auch gar nicht auf intensivstationen
waren und auch in der statistik nicht
auftauchen aber wegen wirklich viele
viele fälle an von leuten die monatelang
total fertig sind massiv eingeschränkt
und dann natürlich diese psychischen
folgen für bestimmte gruppen in dieser
zeit es gibt jetzt inzwischen viele
forschungsprojekte die versuchen das
irgendwie zu messen und zu
quantifizieren ich gebe auch zu das ist
nicht nur eine fachliche baustelle da
gibt es kollegen die kennen sich da sehr
sehr viel besser aus aber ich weiß dass
das einfach natürlich schwierig ist das
in der ähnlichen weise zu quantifizieren
wie man das mit anderen phänomenen tun
kann und ich würde mir wirklich wünschen
dass wird da noch genauer hingucken und
wenn ich noch einen satz sagen darf
wir alle müssen ja auch sozusagen auf
unsere psychische gesundheit gucken
jetzt mit blick auf diesen winter das
fast uns nämlich alle wirklich sehr sehr
an
und darüber wird mir auch ein bisschen
zu wenig gesprochen das ist wieder mal
gesprochen ließ es jetzt mit den
maßnahmen sind die ok und hätte man und
so weiter und so fort
wichtig ist einfach dass wir darüber
reden wie wir alle damit zurechtkommen
abgesehen von den wirtschaftlichen
herausforderungen für betroffene gruppen
und da kommt darum den sonst so dass man
bei sowas immer noch ein tabuthema ist
gerade über die psyche zu sprechen
ich habe hier eine sache die möchte ich
ihnen weiterleiten von axel finger auf
facebook der sagt schön mal die sache
aus der sichtweise einen sehr
kompetenten und sympathischen ethikerin
zu hören
das freut uns vielen dank für das lob
die haben ja gerade schon mal darüber
gesprochen abwägungen das muss die ganze
zeit stattfinden eine abwägung ist ja
auch immer eine demo in der demokratie
eigentlich eine sache von parlamenten
wollen miteinander diskutiert das hat er
hier nicht stattgefunden in den letzten
monaten und als heute im bundestag
debattiert wurde nach der
regierungserklärung da hat sich fdp-chef
lindner auch sofort gemeldet klar als
fraktionschef und der war über diese
tatsache überhaupt nicht amüsiert wie
hört mal rein
der deutsche bundestag kann diesen
beschluss nur noch nachträglich zur
kenntnis nehmen solche
entscheidungsprozesse gefährden nicht
nur die akzeptanz der korona maßnahmen
sie enthalten auch erhebliche rechtliche
risiken und drohen unsere
parlamentarische demokratie zu
reformieren sollte jetzt die passende
frage ich hatte mir auch eine
aufgeschrieben aber ich lasse im user
den vortritt auf facebook kevin köhler
gibt es irgendeine ethische
rechtfertigung für die untätigkeit und
mangelnde parlamentarische beteiligung
über den sommer vor eintritt der zweiten
welle frau wuchs also die da kann ich
natürlich jetzt nicht ganz präzise
kommentieren weil ich nicht einschätzen
kann ob sie stimmt mit der untätigkeit
ich in meiner wahrnehmung war da keine
untätigkeit also es ging ja eine jugend
kaum was anderes als corinna die ganze
zeit aber bestimmt über die
parlamentarische beteiligung die einfach
nicht da war oder nicht da ist seit
monaten teilweise auch freiwillig die
parlamente haben
hergegeben haben gesagt okay ihr macht
jetzt erstmal aber dass er die frage
wann ist denn der punkt gekommen dass
man jetzt sagen muss zuerst müssen alle
wieder mit entscheiden dürfen
also wenn es dann wieder so ein quatsch
punkt ist wie jetzt gerade muss es
einfach natürlich schnell gehen jetzt
werden allerdings die länder land
landesparlamente in sehr vielen
bundesländern beteiligt die das erste
mal vergeben
breite geht also ich glaube schon auch
das ist sehr wichtig ist dass wir
insgesamt eine ganz breite
gesellschaftliche debatte zu diesen
dingern dazu gehört auch eine
parlamentarische beteiligung dazu gehört
aber auch mehr bürger partizipation also
da sehe ich auch wirklich defizite dass
wir es ist hier ganz am anfang gerade
wirklich sehr sehr gute partizipative
formate gegeben also wir das war es das
kennen sicherlich einige das war ein
sehr schneller und hecke tonnen mit
70.000 leuten ist also wirklich tolles
format und es gibt ja ganz viele andere
am solcher formate
das ist in meiner sicht tatsächlich im
sommer nicht genug passiert
das ist ein bereich in dem ich natürlich
sehr viel mehr sagen kann als jetzt
diese staatsrechtliche frage der
parlamentarische beteiligung und ich
würde mir mehr bürgerbeteiligung
wünschen denn da gibt es ein irrsinniges
potenzial an wahnsinnig kreativen ideen
klima jetzt ja auch nicht einfach kluge
beiträge und vorschläge die
berücksichtigt oder eingebracht werden
sollten und wir müssen uns in der
lebendigen demokratie natürlich auch
austauschen und das sollte eben nicht
nur über sagen medien und soziale medien
und so weiter passieren sondern
tatsächlich auch durch eine echte
beteiligung also in echten diskursiven
austausch da wünsche ich mir mehr da ist
die große frage wieso war stattfinden
kann und da sind wir auch noch
tatsächlich in den kinderschuhen um das
mal mit so einer plattitüde zu sagen ich
hab mir mal angeguckt was sie im märz
empfohlen haben bei gab es eine ad hoc
empfehlung vom deutschen ethikrat die
haben sie relativ schnell zusammen
geschrieben deswegen ad hoc empfehlungen
und darin heißt es ich muss es kurz
vorlesen man müsste der öffentlichkeit
erläutern wie unter und welt unter
welchen voraussetzungen wege zurück in
einen zustand der normalität beschritten
wird
können erste frage dazu warum ist das so
wichtig das war im märz ziemlich früh
eigentlich nachdem der wirklich erste
lockdown begonnen hatte und was wird
damit damals gesagt gehört mit zu den
ersten die relativ deutlich darauf
hingewiesen haben dass es nicht nur
einen ganz klaren weg gibt sondern dass
es mit dem echten ethischen konflikt zu
tun an die welt schon wieder haben ja
über den rehmer die ganze zeit auf der
einen seite schutz des
gesundheitssystems und eindämmung der
pandemie auch übrigens nicht nur um der
gesundheit wegen sondern natürlich auch
in der wirtschaft willen und
gleichzeitig hat das folgeschäden
das sind echte ethische konflikte wir
haben das glaube ich mit als erste als
ethische konflikte beschrieben dass das
wirklich schwierig ist und es dann nicht
irgendwie so eine straight forward ansa
also eine klare antwort gibt die so
schnitt und der musiker
das haben wir damals schon gesagt und
wir haben damals natürlich auch gehofft
wie gesagt das war ein märz dass man
vielleicht über normalität oder eine
neue form der normalität schon wieder
früher wird sprechen können also da will
ich ganz offen zugeben wie alle die über
diese pandemie am anfang geschrieben
haben das volle ausmaß war uns nicht in
die dauer stand uns da noch nicht vor
augen jetzt ebenfalls bei diesem
herausgehobene zitat dann wir haben
ansonsten eigentlich eher über öffnungs
perspektiven gesprochen und nicht so
sehr über normalität also unsere schon
klar dass da jetzt auch nicht sofort die
normalität einziehen kann
aber es ging uns einfach darum darauf
hinzuweisen wir müssen immer dieses hin
und her
es gab mal dieses schöne papier das kind
vielleicht einige das ist der hammer und
der tanz und das war in der zeit des
hammers und wir haben damit im prinzip
schon angedeutet und danach kommt der
tanz dieses ständige probieren wie wie
viel können wir zu lassen
wie kriegen wir das ganze irgendwie so
hin dass wir gemeinsam einen weg finden
das alles funktioniert ohne dass es uns
wieder vor die wand fährt
und jetzt waren wir leider schon wieder
beim oder sind wir im moment noch in
einer dynamik
die wir uns ziemlich nah an die wand und
so wir sind jetzt eigentlich schon fast
durch mit den wichtigsten fragen aber
ich habe noch so ein potpourri an
verschiedenen fragen hier offen
einmal gibt es auch kritik an ihrer
position des käfer schreibt sie
argumentieren ganz klar pro
bundesregierung der findet das schade
ich habe auch kritik gehört wenn ich
ehrlich sein soll
dann habe ich hier eine spende frage
auch von ekkehard voigt auf facebook ob
sie es für ethisch gerechtfertigt halten
den individuellen datenschutz
einzuschränken
zum beispiel über eine personalisierte
tracking app wie es das in china gibt
sicher auch utilitaristische aber ist
politik nicht immer militärisch ich
freue mich jetzt das wort ohne fehler
aussprechen konnte frau gut aber halten
sie das china scheint damit ganz gut zu
fahren mit einem relativ totalitären
ansatz datenschutz ist ein fremdwort
rechtfertigt das dann quasi den
gesundheitsschutz der allgemeinheit
argument pro regierung soll ich gucke
mir die maßnahmen an
und darüber haben wir ja gesprochen und
in diesem fall finde ich die
entscheidung richtig fand auch schon
entscheidung falsch aber in diesem fall
muss ich sagen konnte fand ich das
richtig das ist eine echt gute frage mit
dem datenschutz wir haben diese app
gebaut also wirklich die ist dagegen
stärkeren datenschutz in der umsetzung
des gibt es kaum
deswegen kann die auch ganz viel licht
und dann muss man natürlich jetzt so
langsam wirklich fragen und da bin ich
nicht die einzige das haben sehr kluge
kollegen von mir auch schon gefragt wir
schränken so viele grundrechte ein und
die datenschutz so gar nicht bei dem
sind wir also bis auf punkt und komma
extrem präzise es fehlt fast nur noch
das da steht es könnte sein dass sie
eventuell vielleicht einen kontakt
gehabt haben aber können wir nicht genau
sagen na ja also das ist schon sehr sehr
zurückhaltend und da muss ich sagen ich
glaube da gibt es inzwischen auch als
ethischer perspektive wirklich gute
argumente zu sagen also ihr lieben leute
vielleicht kann man da ein bisschen
bisschen zurückhaltender sein mit den
absolut perfekten datenschutz und dieser
app noch die ein oder andere funktionen
dazu gehen dass sie zumindest mal an die
gruppen die an die an die
gesundheitsämter melden kann das kann
die ja auch nicht dieser überhaupt mit
mix verbunden
das ist ja alles komplett freiwillig und
komplett so verschlüsselt ist also
will ich auch gut dass wir da in
deutschland einen starken datenschutz
haben aber ich glaube da hamma
vielleicht doch da kamen potenzial mit
blick auf die ganzen anderen grundrechte
einschränken
noch mehr hilfe aus dieser app zu holen
wenn wir da ein bisschen sozusagen
runter regulieren also da habe ich eine
sympathie für den kommentaren und sich
ganz offen sagen und damit allein
dann habe ich hier noch eine
abschlussfrage die auch unterschiedlich
formuliert so aufgetaucht ist von marc
lotz auf facebook spielt es aus
ethischer sicht bei der abwägung eine
rolle dass das durchschnittliche alter
der korona toten ungefähr der
durchschnittlichen lebenserwartung
entspricht also sprich alles was eine
empirische aussage muss man überprüfen
denn im moment stimmt es nicht mehr wie
sie haben wir haben leider auch jüngere
tote haben sich also die altersklasse
ein bisschen verschoben
aber es stimmt natürlich insgesamt das
dass die algen mensch trifft ich kenne
eine studie die gezeigt hat die
untersucht hat und jetzt muss ich echt
gestehe ich weiß gibt es in deutschland
oder in einem anderen land aber es ist
eine interessante studie die ich damals
verbringen möchte die und die eine
kohorte von gestorbenen ziemlich alten
corinna patienten untersucht hat
ziemlich ordentliche sample und gefunden
hat dass die nicht etwa in liga drei
wochen danach sowieso gestorben werden
sondern fünf jahre im schnitt verloren
haben
das ist nicht nichts muss man einfach so
sagen also fünf lebensjahre ist eben das
klingt ja so ein bisschen polemisch
gestellt die frage also respekt sehr
kernig ich könnte auch schon anfragen
ist es überhaupt ethisch vertretbar so
eine frage zu stellen
ja viele dieser fragen ich finde man
sollte keine fragen verbieten das ist
ganz wichtig aber viele fragen haben
natürlich schieben dinge die man erst
mal auseinander klar sein müsste aber
weil dieser frage ist es wirklich
wichtig die impliziert eben etwas was
einfach so empirisch nicht zutrifft
fragen sollte man eigentlich alles
dürfen also das finde ich schon sehr
wichtig das ist ein sehr schönes ab
das wort vielen dank dass ihr heute
abend zeit für uns hat eine frau
professor biggs ich bedanke mich bei
allen zuschauern den menschen und den
echt wirklich ordentlich konstruktiven
und freundlichen größtenteils
anmerkungen fragen das hat spaß gemacht
und das hat sage ich sehr gern bis zum
nächsten mal
macht's gut und tschüss